hi my name is Tony rich and I'm the
executive director of the st. Louis
chess club one of the organizers of a
couple of grand chests tour stops I'm
also joined by Michael cord Akatsuki
executive director of the grand chest
tour and Vlad are delano the managing
director of super bat our sponsor in
Romania we're here to give you some
important information and exciting news
about the 20 20 grand chest tour season
and for all the details I have Michael
critic offski thank you Tony
today is the last day of 2019 branches
tour and its conclusion of the fifth
year of the grand chief store and as
usually we make announcement for 2020
and it's not exception for this year as
well so we would like first of all to
thank all sponsors who joined us this
year in 2019
starting with Abidjan and Africa super
bet in Romania tournament in Zagreb Club
efore of course includes Chess Club
Paris and India and here we are at the
finals in London and we also would like
to thank our future sponsors for 2020
Vivendi in France super bet and super
bad foundation Romania and sent Lewis
Chess Club as well as our sponsors in
Zagreb Croatia these sponsors put
together funds for 2020 Grantchester
which will be held in Bucharest Romania
st. Louis United States Zagreb Croatia
and Paris friends now I would like to
pass microphone to our sponsors from
Romania in general director of super bad
Vlad and Liliana thank you Michael
we are delighted that Grantchester
decided decide
to partner again we super but in Romania
we are definitely excited that
Grantchester will open the tooth 2020
events with the Romanian Bucharest event
and then we are looking forward for an
amazing 2020 in Grantchester so we're
very excited to kick off the 2020 season
and more details will follow but for now
let's get back to this final day of
action for the 2019 grand chest or